und jetzt ist die große neue spd
mannschaft in den bundestag eingezogen
es gibt sozusagen ein klassenfoto kann
man sagen alle zusammen jesus mittag
hier hier sehen direkt mit diesem
allerersten mannschaft oder klassenfoto
wie patricia sagt bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer bei uns im studio gibt es
richtig ärger warum ja es gibt zu recht
ärger guten morgen würden einmal denn
dieses foto die bilder die wir gesehen
haben die sind der absolute gipfel der
masken heuchelei wir erinnern uns die
spd beteiligt an allen entscheidungen
zum thema masken pflicht auch wir haben
in schulen in vielen vielen schulklassen
immer noch die masken weg das heißt die
schülerin und schüler tragen sogar im
unterricht obwohl sie mit abstand sitzen
eine maske und hier stellt man sich
jetzt auf um zu applaudieren sich selbst
zu feiern und natürlich eignung maske
ist unser land doppelmoral nicht zu
überbieten sind es ja überhaupt die
regelungen sonst also gilt überall in
deutschland in schulen masken pflicht
aber im bundestag nicht oder also im
bundestag gilt auch die masken pflicht
ist sogar erst noch verlängert worden
von wolfgang schäuble und dieses tanja
sind absolut deswegen ist ja die kritik
daran auch absolut berechtigt sie geht
bis zum 31 oktober wir sehen ja auch auf
den bildern dass viele der abgeordneten
ihre maske noch in der hand halten oder
sogar um den arm gebunden haben fünf
abgeordnete haben wir gezählt unter
anderem karl lauterbach tragen auch noch
eine maske also das heißt man ist
zusammengekommen offenbar mit maske wie
sich das auch im bundestag dann gehört
wie es zumindest als regel
vorgeschrieben ist dann hat man wohl
gesagt mensch was sie zur top aus ihr
mit maske nehmen sie doch am ufer steht
euch mal ganz gerne eng zusammen und
nimmt sie aber dann sind offenbar alle
hüllen und alle vorbehalte gefahren hat
man gesagt nee stimmt wir haben die wahl
gewonnen jetzt gratulieren wir uns mal
richtig fang an zu applaudieren und das
ganze ohne maske auch müssen wir noch
mal daran erinnern dass er die spd die
pandemische lage erst vor kurzen noch
mit einer längeren also da ist ganz ganz
viel corona angst corona panik mit dabei
aber ins ums feiern geht dann lässt man
im wahrsten des wortes die maske fahrer
namens photo geht also doch noch mal
anschauen auch die wenigen die man
darauf sieht dafür darauf noch einmal
spazieren gehen und ist ermitteln hat
sich olaf scholz genau die sitzung von
dieser neuen
die spd-fraktion die fand ja im
plenarsaal stadt aus corona gründen weil
man da eben schön weit auseinander
setzen kann da gehen die da aus dem
plenarsaal raus und stehen sich schön
dicht aneinander fürs foto der mit saugt
wirklich ganz familiär aussieht und das
kann auch mal ein fotograf immer noch
mal normalerweise tagen die fraktionen
in ihren fraktions sehen da sitzt man
eng an eng gedrängt jetzt ist die
fraktion der spd deutlich stärker seit
der bundestagswahl 206 abgeordnete und
wie du es gerade richtig gesagt hat
haben gesagt hast kommt man jetzt
zusammen oder ist man zusammengekommen
in dem bundestags sitzungssaal dem
großen plenarsaal da passen zurzeit 709
abgeordnete rein deswegen die 206 hatten
reichlich platz und hat extra gewählter
mit die abgeordneten platz haben aber
danach war es einfach so schön man
wollte noch mal zeigen mensch wie stark
wir sind und stellt sich dann ganz eng
gedrängt aneinander fängt sogar noch an
vor lauter lust zu klatschen berauscht
sich am eigenen erfolg und ich frage
mich auch was sollen eigentlich
beispielsweise die wirte denken die
abkassiert wurden die bußgelder bezahlen
mussten weil sie vielleicht den ein oder
anderen gast ohne maske bewirtet hatten
oder überhaupt geöffnet hatten wir
erinnern uns an jagdszenen in parks weil
menschen sich nicht an corona maßnahmen
gehalten hatten und hier im bundestag
stellt sich die stärkste fraktion
angesagt ist uns alles wurst und vor
allen dingen klassenzimmer eben also
hier in berlin wird zumindest dafür
grundschüler jetzt die masken pflicht
fallen wie in einzelnen bundesländern in
sachsen zum beispiel aber immer noch
millionen schüler und schülerinnen
müssen jeden tag die ganze zeit die
ganze schulzeit bis zum mittag oder
nachmittag ihre maske aufbehalten und da
stellt man sich dann lässig in den
bundestag und nimmt die masse also ist
wie gesagt ein schein heiterkeit und
doppelmoral nicht nach überbieten
interessant ja auch die frage konnte
sich karl lauterbach nicht durchsetzen
möglicherweise hat er gerufen lasst die
masken auf man weiß es nicht genau da
müssen wir noch mal nachgehen dem ganzen
aber ganz klar ist er hat dort keine
mehrheit gehabt der siegesrausch der
jubel und das triumphgefühl das hat er
selbst die maske ähnlich anhören wollen
sich nicht durchsetzen gegen karl
lauterbach auch das erzählt die
geschichte ja alle wollten sie wegnehmen
und karl lauterbach sagte nee freunde
also masken pflicht da bin ich immer
noch unbedingt dieses foto bei uns im
studio bild meinung chef philippe piatti
sorgt jetzt für aufregung auch dich
rechts auf warum ja wusste ich das foto
mal ganz genau anschauen und schauen was
da eventuell fehlt was könnte es denn
sein wenn man sich dieses foto mal
anschaut also weil die tochter wird es
sofort ja gesagt ich sehe ganz viele
jacken und hosen und krawatten und
hemden aber die maske fehlt und ehrlich
gesagt mich persönlich stört das
überhaupt nicht in diese menschen ohne
maske dastehen mein problem ist dass
politiker und seit anderthalb jahren
erzählen und vor allem kindern erzählen
dass sie ohne maske wirklich
lebensgefährlich erkranken dürfen ja ich
ja jemand hallo möglich ausnahme und
wirklich bei aller kritik an karl
lauterbach die ich habe der ist
zumindest konsequent siehst du denn
dieses foto ist das foto der doppelmoral
man sieht hier politiker die seit
anderthalb jahren uns dazu zwingen maske
zu tragen gerade in solchen situationen
wenn man nah beieinander ist im
innenraum also da wo es wirklich
lebensgefährlich ist wenn man mal mit
die maske ab setzt ja und hier stehen
sie da wohl massen pflicht im bundestag
gilt und tragen keine maske ich sehe
ehrlich gesagt du eine chance für die da
wieder rauszukommen und zwar wenn sie
das erste was sie im bundestag machen
ist die masken vielleicht abzuschaffen
dann kann man sagen ihr habt es
verstanden ihr wollt es wie die gleichen
regeln haben die ihr habt ansonsten ist
es halt doppelmoral alles geht der ist
hier die haben sie gerade noch
verlängert bis ende oktober also und
dann stellen sie sich zusammen für die
sonne otto was gibt es auch für ein
signal philipp nach außen sondern all
die menschen auch an die schüler gut ist
an berlin am montag dürfen wenigstens
die grundschüler schon mal die maske
ausziehen aber dennoch es gibt noch
genug schüler in deutschland die
stundenlang mit maske im klassenzimmer
sitzen und jetzt sehen wir politiker
fotografieren sich ohne abstand ohne
maske eine ausnahme also ein paar
vereinzelten auch in den hinteren reihen
aber ganz vorne prominent sehen wir karl
lauterbach welches signal mit
schüler müssen die maske tragen aber
auch ganz normale menschen die doppelt
geimpft sind jedoch drei mal geimpft
sind müssen die maske weitere in den
innenräumen tragen ganz ganz vielen
orten und ehrlich gesagt ich bin froh
dass es dieses foto gibt weil hier
passiert endlich mal dass vor der kamera
was wir alle die mit politikern
regelmäßig seit anderthalb jahrzehnten
haben wissen politiker halten sich auch
nicht an alle regeln und die nehmen auch
die maske bei der erstbesten gelegenheit
habe klar fürs foto da stellt sich
markus söder natürlich mit seiner e p2
p3 maske aber selbst wenn er alleine auf
dem berg steht aber politik und ich
spreche jetzt nicht von markus söder mit
dem bereich privat noch nie unterwegs
aber ganz viele politiker streifen die
maske sofort bei der sp erstbesten
gelegenheit ab da ist dieses klassische
phänomen ihren politikern der kamera
sieht und sofort die zigarette
wegschmeißt bloß nix vor einer hat's ja
neulich gesagt wolfgang kubicki bei paul
ronzheimer mehr interview der hat das
zugegeben dass er sich nicht immer an
die korona regeln gehalten hat hat
dadurch ordentlich was eingesteckt
anschließend an kritik auch aus den
reihen auch von den 206 abgeordneten
dort von der spd und jetzt zeigen die
eben auf dem foto ja es ist halt
realität leute es ist realität in
deutschland ja es gibt diese strengen
regeln und die die unsinnig sind die
befolgt man einfach auch nicht immer
offenbar in reihen der spd fraktion
[Musik]